ce sera la première fois que ses
représentants des citoyens vont entrer
en jeu dire en dialogue en discussion en
débat avec les représentants des
parlements des parlements nationaux des
parlements européens du part de la
commission européenne du conseil des
états membres pour définir ensemble la
voie à venir
la voie à suivre dans les décennies à
venir avec l'union parce qu'il est clair
il est évident le monde de demain sera
complètement différent du monde
d'aujourd'hui
ce sera un monde dominé par la chine par
les états unis seront être les chinois
les américains qui vont de plus en plus
décidé sur notre mode vie est ce qu'on
veut créer avec cette conférence c'est
la réponse à la question comment éviter
cela nous on a un modèle européen
nous on aime notre vie privée nous on
aime notre liberté notre façon de faire
notre façon de manger de vivre comment
respecter ça préserver sa dans le monde
de demain ne va pas se faire avec une
union européenne qui a basé sur le règle
de l'unanimité ça ne va pas se faire
avec une union européenne qui qui n'est
pas compétent par exemple pour la santé
publique et d'autres trucs importants
dans la vie quotidien des gens
[Musique]